what are you looking for do i need to
call the police
this is nova scotia's chief medical
officer of health confronting a small
group of protesters outside of his own
home we just want to know why he is
extending the mass mandate protesters
showed up sunday night with signs
reading strangled and unmasked our
children strain can be seen calling
police and relaying a license plate
number to the operator we're really just
like organizing a peaceful protest
you're not supposed to be here anyway
speaking to global news morning on
monday strain called the protests
juvenile and unwelcome they were keeping
us up until i was up until well after
two o'clock with prank phone calls and
things like that the protest was in
response to the province's last minute
decision to keep masting mandates in
place in schools for the next several
weeks the teachers union says this form
of protest is completely offside i think
it's cowardly and disgusting he has a
family and people that he loves and
cares for and they did not sign up to be
public figures this isn't the first time
protesters have shown up outside dr
strein's home another protest happened
in september 2021 in response to proof
of vaccine policies premier tim houston
put the protesters on blast then and has
a similar message now i don't know that
i have a strong enough word to really
express my my emotions to protest at his
home where he lives but also his family
lives is completely inappropriate police
say no arrests were made and everyone
was gone by 3 30 a.m members of the
public have a right to assemble freely
and safely for protests and everyone
else in the public also has a right to
safety as for strain he says the
protesters won't stop him from moving
forward with their plan this is all
about keeping them asking for a few more
weeks to slow down and decrease the
spread of the virus graeme benjamin
global news halifax